ROSS: So Ryan and I were
because we got a
really interesting lead
on a 1969 Cadillac Eldorato.
Now this ain't just
any Eldorado, man.
the seller claims that this
car was once customized
by famous customizer,
George Barris
of the Bat mobile customizing.
I'm hoping that this thing
turns out to be true.
Albert, nice to see you, man.
Albert, Ryan.
RYAN: Nice to meet you.
So this is her.
This is her.
ROSS: 69 Eldorado.
ALBERT: 69 Eldorado, El clasico.
My understanding, it was owned
by the great George Barris,
the creator of the Bat mobile
and the Monsters mobile
and a whole bunch of other cars.
RYAN: This is nuts.
ROSS: George Barris is the
original king of customizers.
His beautiful creations can be
seen in dozens of television
shows and movies, but
his most famous creation
is the Bat mobile,
a 1955 Lincoln
Futura that he transformed into
the Cape Crusaders cruiser.
And his rides are still
sought after today.
That's why if this is
truly a Barris creation,
I'll definitely be in
a buying state of mind.
You know, obviously,
it's a significant vehicle.
But she needs to
be completely done.
And that's a big project.
ALBERT: Oh yeah, she's a beauty.
That's a big--
That's definitely
a big undertaking.
RYAN: Look at all these
handmade moldings.
ROSS: Yeah.
These are not coach
worked moldings.
Someone hand made these.
Here, all around the
back here, as well.
This is all--
RYAN: That's all one piece.
ROSS: Yeah.
You've got to love
the hood ornament.
ALBERT: We call her the lady.
ROSS: It's beautiful.
The custom pieces that
were 100% George Barris,
they're all here.
ALBERT: They're complete.
They're here.
And it runs and drives?
Yeah, it runs and drives.
Can we fire it
up and back it out?
ALBERT: Sure, go for it.
ROSS: I love it.
I love it.
All right.
Here we go.
[music playing]
Yeah, floor issues.
Hand went right through it?
Yup.
We got rust issues.
It's an Eldorado that we
would normally run the hills.
So right now the only
thing it has going
for it is it's George Barris.
- Right.
RYAN: It's history.
It definitely is.
ROSS: Now, what are
you asking on this car?
45.
ROSS: $4,500 bucks for a
beat up, rusted out, old
69 Cadillac Eldorado.
Man, I wouldn't
even have to think
twice about passing on that.
But I can tell you this, man.
The markings and the
designs are 100% George
Barris design on this car.
The guy who built
the Bat mobile, man.
I'm torn.
I really am.
Is that your bottom
number on this car?
Yeah.
RYAN: I was hoping it
was in better condition.
Yeah.
It's got its
pluses and minuses.
It needs everything.
It's got to be redone.
The pluses is all the
custom stuff is here.
That's what makes it valuable.
That's what makes it worth it.
RYAN: Ross, this
one is all on you.
I don't know, man.
This is a decision I would not
want to make if I were you.
Being a car guy, I
think you're being fair.
And if you're being fair, then
I think the least I can do
is be fair right back.
OK.
I'll give you $4,500 for it.
You just bought
yourself a Cadillac.
ROSS: Done deal.
Thank you very much.
ALBERT: Thank you.
We've got our
work cut out for us.
But it's going to be
worth it in the long run.
You rock.
Thank you very, very much.
ALBERT: A pleasure and an honor.
ROSS: Later on today,
they're coming to get her.
We're going to go back
and we're going to tell
everybody what we've done.
What we've done?
ROSS: What we've done.
I'm going to blame it on you.
You're the one that
brought it to me today.
I'm going to blame it on you.
RYAN: Man, you're
killing the messenger.
Catch you later, brother.
Let's go.
Hit the dusty trail.